and nothing's more current than the
personal attack I suffered from Bam
Margera who released a
majorly produced rap song she was fire
as [__] dude yeah so well produced so
well done the energy he put into it
unbelievable where were you when you got
the the note like bam responses people
were you like uh what does this [__]
guy have to say now okay the rap song
came to my attention long before it was
on TMZ I just responded once it was on
TMZ why when did you hear about it I did
I heard about it ages ago because I get
my news from Reddit now
yeah yeah wow yeah I mean I don't check
it as much nearly as I was for a minute
there sure but like every week or two
did you hear it when we were in the UK
yeah I think I I think I did yeah okay I
mean they only released the whole song
like in the last week or so yeah okay so
you saw the teaser yeah the teasers yeah
yeah I saw when bam was actually in the
studio was that a studio in rehab
there was a studio in uh La I think
now kudos to these Australian Mumble
rappers
for uh
you know making a wave and riding it
that's the crew that he did the song
with yeah but do you really think it's
the kind of wave you want to ride
I mean when you're at that frequency
that bams that yeah I mean I don't know
that it was a great way for bam to ride
but I'd think that as far as these
rappers from Australia I think that they
got they got themselves some publicity
some exposure why is he mad at Wee Man
because he escapes he's mad he's mad at
Wee Man for uh being a pro skateboarder
because we man and I had the collab
skateboard and the last time I was in
contact with bam I was like kind of
making a big deal out of uh Wee Man and
I uh competing like Escape
right the Steve is making a competition
out of a filming skateboarding to
promote our board yeah but bam had the
chance to do that too right but Bam's
not big on
um making more than five dollars a board
in sales well I mean yeah he had the
opportunity to do that like I I
presented it to him like let's um you
know let's get on track let's
be sober let's be productive let's let's
do all this great stuff and we can make
a ton of money selling skateboards but
um that didn't pan out and so bam got
mad at me selling skateboards instead
hmm
damn and so you responded on TMZ
I'm selling boards I recorded my
response for TMZ they got it up in
lightning speed same day yeah and then I
put my response on Tick Tock and I saw
it just go you know tick tock's the
stuff either like really really takes
off or it just doesn't do anything and
this one kind of took off and so I
thought okay
let me put that on Instagram and
Facebook
um
and and uh I think it performed all
pretty well so has there been any
response back from bam no
do you think there will be nah or do you
have to hit him back to back
yeah like there's nothing like serious
about it I mean you're not mad at them
I'm not mad at him at all I just think
it's funny plus
um dude just today
I uh
put a story because we're building the
ramp in my backyard and I put up a story
with my goats and the ramp saying that
since uh this personal attack now I'm
building a ramp when in fact I've been
building it yeah I've been like planning
on building this ramp for weeks and for
months
um but that story with the goats in the
ramp in two hours it's uh over a hundred
thousand opens wow I don't know that
I've ever had that much eyeballs on a
story
yeah so Bam's hooking you up Bam's
hooking me up yeah is this Lux brought
up that you know you are a rapper as
well and you could respond with it
right but here's the thing I I um made a
video about my rap career
like how many people have we had on this
podcast where we brought up my rap
career not one of them remembers or knew
that I had a rap career and you're
underground right so like it's just not
something that's so common knowledge now
I will resurrect it
I will I will resurrect it oh my God I
shouldn't even say this but but there
was a a thread a text thread between
some of the jackass guys
and uh we were like text dropping into
the text thread videos that we filmed
selfie videos of us rapping
like out of response
you know to bam yeah I mean stuff that
will never go anywhere never ever see
the light of day but I was like you know
oh my God I mean what did you say at
least can you say what you said yeah
let's hear those Rhymes
let's hear those you should do like a
vinyl pressing of your rap album like
some like a prestigious like crack
cocaine yeah I've got it pulled up here
on discogs.com
um you down with STDs
okay where all right uh I don't even
know what
who did the art for that album
[Music]
you don't just don't know why that makes
you so mad
you still got it wow the kids still got
it
no
Okay can people buy this album is that
where you're at okay
here comes first two then okay
oh my God and this is why I poke the
push until I die but you just cry all
you do is lie I tell you that your bone
spurs is cap and your rap is whack you
get in the octagonal make you tap
yeah that's pretty good those are
fighting words
now he has to choose he could probably
beat me up yeah maybe right uh okay so
uh so again we're just we're not like
being malicious for me and it's just you
know having a laugh
um always wished for bam to get healthy
and be good and and all these things do
you like shopping on Amazon I do and
good news is Stevo's butt wipes for your
butt hole are available on Amazon and if
you want a real bundle of a deal you can
get Stevo's hot sauce for your butt Hall
plus Steven's butthole destroyer and
Stevo's butt wipes for your butthole
it's the butthole bundle available on
Amazon right now yeah
dude